les autres producteurs tout ça et je le
dis c'est quand même pour ça que j'ai
pas l'impression de faire un travail
normalement ils sont comme ça chez eux
et tout ou bien dans leur bureau ils
font des dossiers alors objet alors
concernant le prime time du 22 février
nous avons pensé donc ils font des
dossiers avec des couleurs des trucs ils
expliquent le concept tu vois ou pas ils
mettent voilà un tout eu beau eu de
blague tu vois genre il met des bailles
mais moi ça fait des années que
je n'ai pas fait un dossier un mail
on déjeune
j'ai pas fait un déjeuner avec un mec de
télé depuis 86
même pas né je n'ai pas de déjeuner
frère tu es un fou quoi mais rien j'ai
rien même les textos je réponds même
plus non mais c'est rigoler je vous jure
parce que d'habitude les mecs tout ça
ils font ils font des déjeuner des
producteurs ouais Mathieu la vérité moi
c'est bien moi c'est ce que vous faites
c'est à dire je je papiers et je vais
dans les chaînes et j'attends ouais
j'attends parfois une heure 1h15
on vous dira envoyez-moi un mail
envoyez-moi un budget on vous renverra
gnagnagna ça sera en commission
vous allez voir les chaînes normalement
mais j'ai plus 10 ans que je les ai pas
vu mon échelle il voit pas ils veulent
pas me voir je les vois pas je vois
personne genre rien à et donc et
donc les mecs alors on cherche en ce
moment un prime time un peu festif euh
moi c'est feel good tu vois on cherche
quelque chose de fil good qu'est-ce que
tu as tu vois nous proposer on cherche
un concept français tu vois on a envie
de se démarquer non mais c'est vrai donc
tu vas avec ta petite mallette et tu
arrives devant le mec et tu lui dis
alors et là le gars te regarde comme ça
il est quand même
alors
avec cette tête et les gars ils te
disent toujours ouais mais non ça on l'a
déjà lancé en production
ils ont déjà tout lancé ils ont déjà
tout fait voilà alors qu'en fait ils
vont piquer le concept c'est clair
c'est comme ça c'est vrai ou pas
je suis allé voir j'ai fait le
rendez-vous j'avais préparé 15 dossiers
au début il m'a dit je te préviens on
achètera rien avant 2025
et moi j'ai pas fait un espèce de
panique moi je m'en rappelle un jour
alors faut que je me raconte ce que j'ai
une énorme cadavre j'avais jamais
raconté ça parce qu'à l'époque je
faisais des dossiers et un jour je vais
voir Nicolas pernica qui était directeur
des divertissements non deux de France 2
et sur la tête de ma mère il est comme
as et je lui parle d'une émission je lui
parle d'ailleurs de Touche pas à mon
poste au départ tu vois je fais une
émission avec des chroniques il est
comme ça sourit
[Rires]
et je pense qu'il y a pas une émission
on parle vraiment de télé
[Rires]
tu vois il y a pas vraiment de télé tu
vois tu vois ça et puis bon tu vois je
prends des profils très journalistes tu
vois et moi tu vois je vais je vais
rigoler tout
tu connais ça où il y a
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
sur la tête de ma mère
connais de nom mais bon je suis jamais
vraiment allé quoi non parce que je dis
vacances là pour février
je sais pas du tout ce que je vais faire
et alors c'est quoi ton truc là
ouais écoute là c'est pas le moment là
ce que je suis en train de chercher des
vacances
mais t'inquiète pas on va voir ce qu'on
va faire de toute façon voilà mais je
vous jure histoire tu connais sawira
elle était extraordinaire
quand tu vas revenir là il revient là
cette semaine
plus que toi
[Applaudissements]
on a pas l'impression de faire un
travail non mais c'est vrai sans
charrier on a pas l'impression
franchement on vient moi je vous dis à
la tech c'est 8 et merci à C8 face à
Baba comme je voulais je voulais
raconter la dernière fois même la grosse
rigolade
vous savez même pas comment ça allait
s'appeler voilà tout tout voilà même
TPMP people on n'a pas fait de dossier
non
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'était tout le contraire vous aviez pas
de réponse avant 6 mois dans des détails
en plus il vous disent de perdre votre
accent un peu du Sud-Ouest et cetera les
choses aimes pour réussirez jamais toute
façon si vous gardez cet accent etc etc
etc six mois au moins il fallait jamais
avant jamais vous ça c'est pas fallu 6
ans toi plutôt
vous savez j'ai de la chance parce que
j'ai jamais rien demandé en réalité moi
j'avais démarré
[Rires]
je vous explique monsieur Hanouna non
non j'avais démarré avec télé connexions
qui était la première mission sur les
coulisses de la télévision
vidéo gag 14 ans la famille en or deux
ans et c'est parce que c'est moi qui ai
décidé d'arrêter et tout ça on me l'a
proposé
spectateurs merci et pourquoi tu
pourquoi ils t'ont viril non c'est moi
qui ai déconné
[Applaudissements]
en fait j'avais proposé alors j'étais
content de faire vidéo gag si 7 millions
à chaque fois à chaque émission le
dimanche
comme quoi à l'époque la télé c'était
beaucoup plus en plus
un chat qui pétait tu faisais 7 millions
non mais aujourd'hui tu te fais chier à
faire des trucs de fou les gars ils font
Ninja Warrior avec des trucs et tout ils
font 1 million si c'est lui il arrive il
y a deux chats qui pètent
tu as un chien qui tombe une échelle
quand on entend entendre je pense
c'est les seuls problèmes avec moi et
notre tristesse ça veut dire que tu
pouvais voir un mec tomber dans une
cuisine Patrick fais attention il y a de
l'eau derrière
chaque mignon aujourd'hui tu fais ça
c'est 200000 et barre-toi les quatre ans
cette connerie en plus ça leur coûte
rien parce que à l'époque les gens en
fait parce que lui il est de l'époque
frère c'était des gens filmés avec un
caméscope
allez acheter un caméscope mon frère ça
veut dire ils allaient chez Darty ou
chez Boulanger ou je sais pas où le
weekend ils allaient acheter un
caméscope pour fournir leur émission qui
leur coûtait 0 alors c'est parce qu'en
fait c'est avec des images de gars qui
leur envoyait
sélectionner tu gagnes la caméscope
la meilleure
autant vous dire que vous avez affaire
au plus grand escroc du 21e siècle non
mais c'est quand même incroyable qui a
gagné les sous là-dessus c'est qui le
producteur de ça parce que je vais lui
parler moi
la réalité moi j'avais vu ça aux
États-Unis j'étais venu à rien
mais c'est pourquoi tu sais comment tu
vendais ça on prend je crois la vérité
je suis maintenant que ça devait écouter
700 800000
mais non mais déjà c'était le dimanche
700 800000 francs ouais frère
si ça te coûter 15000 balles je viens
alors pour être honnête soyons honnête
avec des spectateurs comme toujours
figurez-vous qu'au début c'était pas
réflexe français de filmer ou les
mariages ou les baptêmes ou quoi que ce
soit les Français n'étaient pas habitués
au caméscope nous achetions les images
aux États-Unis et en Angleterre ou dans
les pays ouais donc ça c'est bon et
heureusement c'est pour ça qu'on a lancé
avec des grandes marques on a offert de
ma gueule
internet avait pris le relais ah ouais
toutes ces vidéos on les trouvait sur
Internet c'était moins intéressant pour
moi c'est fou toi tu as une histoire
de fou quoi
toi c'est intéressant